Y aquí viene el lío:
"pero como eres suyo retiré la mano y te dejé"
(Risas)
Traduzcan eso.
(Aplausos)
¿Qué hacemos entonces para proteger la lengua árabe?
Llevamos la cuestión al nivel de la sociedad civil
y lanzamos una campaña para preservar la lengua árabe.
aunque mucha gente nos decía: "¿qué más da?"
"Diviértanse, no se preocupen tanto".
¡No pasa nada!
Nuestra campaña tenía por lema:
"Te hablo desde Oriente y me respondes desde Occidente".
No dijimos: "no vamos a aceptar esto, porque esta es nuestra lengua, etc".
No usamos ese estilo porque no creemos que deba hacerse así,
si alguien me habla así odiaría la lengua árabe.
Decimos....
(Aplausos)
Queremos ver cómo vivimos nuestra realidad
de una manera similar a nuestros sueños, nuestro día a día, nuestros anhelos,
de una manera que vista nuestra ropa, que piense como nosotros.
Nuestro lema "Te hablo desde Oriente y me respondes desde Occidente",
pone el dedo en la llaga,
es sencillo, creativo y convincente.
Después empezamos otra campaña,
pusimos letras en la calle,
(a lo mejor las vieron ahí fuera)
y alrededor de ellas una cinta policial
en la que decía: "¡No mates tu lengua!".
¿Por qué? De verdad, no debemos matar nuestra lengua.
Entre todos debemos evitar matar nuestra lengua.
Porque si la matamos, cuando volvamos en busca de nuestra identidad,
cuando volvamos en busca de nuestra existencia,
tendremos que volver a empezar desde cero,
no solo no seremos capaces de ser modernos y desarrollados.
También tomamos fotos de chicos y chicas vestidos con letras árabes.
Fotos de chicos y chicas "cool".
¡Nosotros somos muy "cool"!
Habrá quien diga: "Has usado una palabra inglesa, ¡te atrapamos!"
No, he adoptado la palabra "cool".
Les reto a encontrar una palabra más bella
y más adecuada.
Seguiré diciendo "Internet",
y no "red de redes".
(Risas)
¡No vale igual! ¿Es broma o qué?
Pero para llegar a este punto tenemos que estar todos convencidos.
No queremos dejar al más fuerte,
al que cree tener el poder sobre la lengua,
que nos domine y nos obligue a pensar y sentir como él quiere.
La clave está en la creatividad.
Si no podemos llegar al espacio o construir un cohete,
podemos crear.
En este momento, cada uno de Uds. es un proyecto creativo.
La creatividad en la lengua materna es el camino
Empecemos ahora, desde este momento.
Escribamos una novela, rodemos un corto.
Una sola novela puede dar la vuelta al mundo,
puede devolver la lengua árabe a lo más alto.
No digan que no hay solución. ¡Por supuesto que la hay!
Tenemos que estar convencidos de que hay solución,
y tenemos que ser parte de ella.
Para terminar, ¿qué se puede hacer desde hoy?
¿Quién de aquí tiene Twitter?
Por favor, se lo suplico, aunque mi tiempo se agote,
en árabe, o en inglés, o en francés o en chino.
¡Pero no escriban árabe usando letras latinas y números!
(Aplausos)
¡Eso es un desastre! ¡No es ninguna lengua!
Es un mundo virtual, una lengua virtual
y ya nadie nos podrá sacar de ahí.
Eso es lo primero que podemos hacer.
Segundo, hay muchas cosas que podemos hacer.
Nosotros no estamos aquí para convencer a nadie,
sino para advertir de que debemos cuidar nuestra lengua.
Ahora les contaré un secreto.
Cuando nace un niño, la primera manera con que conoce a su padre
es la lengua.
Así que cuando nazca mi hija le diré: "Este es papá, mi vida". [árabe]
Y no le diré: "This is your dad, honey".
Y en el supermercado, cuando mi hija Nour
dé las gracias en árabe
no le diré: "Dit merci !", deseando que nadie la hubiera escuchado.
(Aplausos)
Superemos este complejo frente a lo extranjero.